-Il s'est d'abord
fait connaître comme chercheur
spécialiste
des relations internationales,
mais un chercheur engagé,
presque militant.
Rien d'étonnant, puisqu'il baigne
dans la politique depuis ses 18 ans.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Benjamin Haddad.
-Bonjour.
-Une anecdote m'a fait sourire
quand j'ai préparé l'émission.
C'est la réaction de votre mère
quand vous lui avez dit
que vous vouliez prendre
votre carte dans un parti
alors que
vous étiez encore au lycée.
-Oui. J'ai été élevé par des parents
qui ont la passion
du travail, des études.
Sa réaction a été :
"Passe ton bac
"et puis Sciences Po d'abord".
J'ai toujours été
passionné de politique,
mais j'ai pris ma carte
une fois à Sciences Po.
-Qu'est-ce qui
vous rendait si impatient
de vous engager ?
-J'ai toujours eu
cette passion. J'ai été au lycée
à un moment très politisé.
Jean-Marie Le Pen
était au 2e tour en 2002.
Moi, j'ai eu mon bac en 2003.
On avait eu le 11 septembre.
Beaucoup de sujets étaient brûlants,
en politique intérieure
et en relations internationales.
Et à un moment,
on a ça en soi.
On a envie de donner
un sens à sa vie
qui dépasse sa propre personnalité.
J'ai passé du temps
en tant que militant.
-Donc, Jeune Populaire, à l'époque ?
-Jeune Pop, oui,
à l'UMP.
-Les jeunes de l'UMP.
-Oui, l'UMP présidée
par Marie Guévenoux,
qui est aujourd'hui
députée de Renaissance.
A tracter, coller des affiches,
à écumer les meetings,
à participer à la campagne
de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007...
-Vous aviez 21 ans.
Vous n'avez pas participé
en petite main.
Vous avez rédigé des notes,
des discours
sur le volet international.
-J'étais passionné
par l'international.
Après un stage
dans un think tank américain
en 3e année de Sciences Po,
j'ai commencé à travailler
avec David Martinon,
conseiller diplomatique
de Nicolas Sarkozy,
qui avait organisé une équipe
pour préparer le programme
de politique étrangère :
des notes, des discours,
des éléments de langage.
Mais j'ai aussi participé
en tant que
militant actif sur le terrain.
-David Martinon,
vous l'avez suivi dans sa campagne
aux municipales
de Neuilly-sur-Seine.
Et à partir de 2009,
c'est en première ligne
que vous êtes apparu
comme jeune copéiste.
*-Je voulais juste dire un petit mot
de "Génération France"
et de "Génération France Jeunes"
que vous connaissez.
C'est un think tank,
donc un cercle de réflexion
qui a été créé
par Jean-François Copé
depuis quelques années
pour promouvoir le débat,
ouvrir au maximum
la réflexion politique
à la société civile,
aux entrepreneurs,
aux intellectuels, aux jeunes,
à ceux qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de s'engager
dans un parti politique,
dans une logique militante
pour participer aux débats.
-Vous étiez responsable
du mouvement "Génération France",
un think tank, comme vous dites,
un cercle de réflexion.
Il y en a eu deux autres
par la suite, on va en parler,
des think tanks.
Pour certains, la politique,
c'est l'action. Pour vous,
c'est d'abord la réflexion,
l'intellectualisation ?
-Non, c'est l'action
au service des idées.
Je suis engagé,
militant pour mes convictions,
un spectateur engagé.
-Pour défendre vos idées.
-Oui.
Dans l'engagement politique,
on a des leviers
d'action opérationnels
pour pouvoir agir
et c'est bien l'objectif.
-Par la suite,
Jean-François Copé a misé sur vous
quand il a pris la tête de l'UMP.
Il vous a nommé
secrétaire national. Vous,
pourquoi avez-vous
misé sur lui à l'époque ?
-C'est quelqu'un pour qui
j'ai toujours beaucoup d'amitié.
J'ai été à l'UMP parce que je suis
un libéral, un réformateur,
un Européen. Il incarnait ça.
Il avait aussi donné
beaucoup de dynamisme au groupe.
-A l'Assemblée, vous voulez dire ?
-Absolument.
Il était président du groupe UMP
à l'Assemblée nationale.
C'était un groupe
assez actif, autonome.
J'étais attiré par ça.
Et puis, en effet,
il y avait ce think tank
où venaient des gens de gauche,
de droite, des experts
de la société civile pour débattre.
Là, le débat portait
sur l'Education nationale.
Une période stimulante.
-Intellectuellement.
On en revient toujours aux idées.
En 2014, vous demandez
à Jean-François Copé
de vous envoyer en Ukraine,
en plein soulèvement
du peuple à Kiev.
Vous y allez au nom de l'UMP
pour rencontrer
les partis d'opposition.
Selon vous, ce voyage a été
le tournant de votre engagement.
C'est-à-dire ?
-Déjà, ça a été un moment
passionnant, intense,
très émouvant.
Vous avez cette place Maïdan à Kiev
où des dizaines de milliers
de jeunes viennent se rassembler
pendant des mois,
il fait moins 15 degrés,
dans des tentes,
avec des drapeaux européens.
C'est la première fois
dans l'histoire
que des gens se font tuer
parce qu'ils brandissent
le drapeau européen
qui, pour eux, est la promesse
de la démocratie,
de la lutte contre la corruption
et d'un avenir européen.
Nous sommes en 2014.
En France, on place le FN
en tête de l'élection européenne.
Le Brexit est proche.
On est blasés,
cyniques par rapport
à l'idéal européen
qu'incarnent les jeunes Ukrainiens.
C'est un moment fort.
C'est un moment où j'ai voulu
m'éloigner de la politique
plus classique.
-C'est là où j'en viens.
Vous dites
que ce Maïdan
vous a rendu à nouveau idéaliste.
Or, la leçon que vous en tirez,
c'est de quitter la politique.
C'est étonnant.
-C'est vrai que comme
beaucoup de collègues,
de gauche comme de droite,
je ne me reconnaissais plus
dans ce que le clivage
droite-gauche avait à offrir.
Je voyais la droite, l'UMP,
qui était prise dans
des querelles de personnalités,
d'égo,
qui commençait à se crisper
sur des questions
d'identité et de société.
J'étais favorable
au mariage pour tous.
J'ai vu beaucoup de dirigeants
de droite aller manifester.
Donc,
j'ai décidé de prendre du recul.
-Vous partez à Washington
et devenez chercheur
dans le think tank
Hudson Institute.
Voyez-vous cela
comme une autre forme
d'engagement que la politique ?
On a le sentiment que vous êtes
un chercheur engagé.
-Absolument.
Déjà, j'arrive à un moment
passionnant, fin 2014.
Quelques mois plus tard,
Donald Trump
déclare sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle. Pendant un an,
tous mes amis américains,
républicains comme démocrates,
nous disent : "Il n'a aucune chance,
il va imploser en plein vol."
Ils n'ont pas vu venir.
Je crois que c'était
un avertissement pour l'Europe.
Après ça, j'ai compris
que Marine Le Pen et les populistes
pouvaient l'emporter,
qu'il fallait
rester engagé et que Trump n'était
pas un accident de l'histoire.
Aux Etats-Unis, on voyait un repli
des Américains sur eux-mêmes,
un retrait d'Europe,
une volonté de ne plus intervenir
dans des conflits
au Moyen-Orient ou ailleurs
avec des conséquences
sur notre sécurité.
Les Européens devaient en tirer
les conclusions.
-Ce qui est étonnant,
c'est que ce think tank
Hudson Institute
puis le 2e, Atlantic Council,
sont des cercles de réflexion
considérés comme atlantistes
proaméricains. Vous,
à l'intérieur de ces cercles,
vous défendez l'Europe autonome,
souveraine, indépendante,
l'Europe puissance.
Ils vous en ont voulu ?
Vous les avez dérangés ?
-Parfois,
j'ai été le poil à gratter.
Mais quand j'ai dirigé le centre
Europe de l'Atlantic Council,
je les ai convaincus
de faire un centre qui,
pour la 1re fois aux Etats-Unis,
parlait de l'Union européenne.
Aux Etats-Unis, l'Europe était vue
à travers l'OTAN ou les relations
avec les Etats membres.
Mais l'Union européenne,
sur le plan de la régulation
des nouvelles technologies,
sur le plan commercial, militaire...
Les Américains
sont un peu schizophréniques.
D'un côté, ils disent qu'ils vont
se retirer de l'Europe et que
les Européens doivent plus investir
dans leur défense.
Et tant mieux. Et quand on le fait,
quand on essaie d'unir l'Europe et
les instruments de la souveraineté,
généralement, ils braquent,
voire s'y opposent.
Donc, un dialogue
transatlantique important
doit être mis en place
entre alliés démocratiques,
mais il y a
une relation à réinventer.
C'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
des deux côtés de l'Atlantique.
-Ce que vous avez fait
avec votre livre
"Le paradis perdu" paru en 2019
où vous évoquez
l'avènement du trumpisme
et développez un concept
émergé quelques années avant,
celui de l'autonomie stratégique.
Or, 7 mois plus tard,
Emmanuel Macron
en parle dans une interview
à "The Economist".
Il y a un lien ?
Vous étiez en contact ?
Parce que vous l'avez rencontré
à Washington dès 2015.
Est-ce que vous lui aviez envoyé
votre livre ?
Vous avez pu l'influencer ?
-Emmanuel Macron
s'intéresse beaucoup
à ces débats et ces questions.
Il a mis l'Europe
au coeur de sa campagne,
c'est ce qui m'a attiré dès 2007,
en m'engageant aux Etats-Unis
dans sa campagne avec lui.
Je crois qu'il est hanté par l'idée
que l'Europe pourrait se retrouver
à disparaître,
à n'être qu'un théâtre
des rivalités
entre les Etats-Unis et la Chine,
sans parvenir à avoir sa propre
voie, à défendre ses intérêts.
-Mais pensez-vous avoir nourri
sa réflexion sur ce sujet ?
-Il se nourrit
de beaucoup d'experts,
de beaucoup de rencontres.
Il est toujours à l'écoute
et ouvert à ces échanges.
Il s'intéresse aux idées.
-Votre rencontre avec
Emmanuel Macron date de 2015.
Vous vous engagez avec lui en 2017
à Washington
avec le comité En Marche
sur place, localement.
Mais vous avez laissé passer
les législatives pour
vous présenter finalement en 2022.
Vous revenez en France
et vous présentez à Paris
dans le 16e arrondissement.
Qu'est-ce qui motive ce retour
en politique, alors que
vous aviez été déçu en 2015 ?
-Je crois que
les 5 prochaines années
sont fondamentales pour le pays.
Il y a un risque
que l'extrême droite
arrive au pouvoir,
il y a des réformes fondamentales
à faire au niveau national,
mais aussi européen.
Ma famille...
Mon père n'est pas né en France.
Une famille qui s'est intégrée,
qui a fui l'antisémitisme
en Tunisie
et qui est très reconnaissante
à la République,
qui a travaillé dur pour s'intégrer.
Je me suis toujours senti redevable,
l'engagement ne m'a pas quitté.
C'était le moment
de franchir le cap.
-A l'Assemblée,
vous présidez
le Groupe d'amitié avec l'Ukraine.
Vous rencontrez Zelensky
deux fois : à l'Atlantic Council
et depuis que
vous êtes député également.
Cette guerre en Ukraine,
elle réunit les valeurs
pour lesquelles vous vous battez :
la liberté, l'Europe, la démocratie.
Mais cette bataille
pour ces valeurs,
ne la meniez-vous pas de manière
plus efficace en tant que chercheur
engagé et militant ?
-Non.
Ce sont des rôles différents.
Dans le cadre de l'Assemblée,
il y a un soutien
à ce que fait la France.
-Mais vous n'êtes pas
aux commandes en tant que ministre.
-Naturellement.
Mais il y a les livraisons d'armes,
le fonds de soutien à l'Ukraine
que le groupe a fait doubler
lors du débat budgétaire.
Je crois à la diplomatie
parlementaire. Notre assemblée
a un rôle à jouer
dans ce soutien à l'Ukraine.
Les Ukrainiens sont reconnaissants
du soutien de la France,
mais aussi de ces échanges
qu'ils peuvent avoir
avec les Parlementaires.
-On va passer à notre quizz.
Voici la règle :
je commence une phrase
et c'est à vous de la compléter.
On y va.
"Depuis que je suis député,
j'évite de..."
-J'évite de céder à la facilité
de la violence, du clash.
C'est un monde de conflits,
on se bat pour des idées.
Mais c'est un monde qui peut aussi
vite céder aux conflits
de personnes et j'évite cela.
-"Un bon porte-parole,
c'est comme
"un bon prof..."
Etes-vous porte-parole
du groupe Renaissance ?
-J'ai enseigné.
C'est différent parce que...
J'ai toujours aimé
l'enseignement très interactif.
Je faisais beaucoup lire
mes étudiants,
j'essayais de les faire
s'exprimer sur le sujet.
Pour moi, c'est
la meilleure façon d'enseigner.
Un porte-parole parle
plus qu'il n'écoute.
-Il y a la pédagogie.
-Oui, vous avez raison.
En revanche, la politique,
c'est énormément d'écoute.
Dans une campagne,
c'est là où l'on parle le moins.
On vient rencontrer
les gens sur le terrain.
Et ça, ça peut être proche
d'un bon prof qui est dans
la pédagogie, l'échange et l'écoute.
-"Ce qui me manque le plus
"de la vie américaine, c'est..."
-Je ne sais pas.
J'avais une vie
intéressante et agréable,
mais sinon...
-Vous préférez
la vie française ?
-Bien sûr.
-Merci, Benjamin Haddad.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA